rejection Ninja Turtles
yeah we're gonna watch Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Mutant Mayhem today John
and Andrew they watched TMNT the
animated flick from many years ago I did
a watch with Aaron Alexander for the
Michael Bay produced ones but he already
saw this one in the theaters scab
and it's the three of us today and I'm
excited to check this out because I hear
great things about it and you bring a
witty comment I've said it before and
I'll say it again man I love being a
part of citizen of the rejection
Ah that's a call back that's a callback
I love a Good callback you know what I
also like I like when people realize
that it was Greg's birthday this week
and what is the best present you can
give Greg this week especially after he
just went to Urgent Care over the
weekend his birthday weekend what's he
doing he's using his birthday and pity
like the ultimate YouTuber to tell you
guys about our new merch shop reject
nationshop.com that's right guys we have
left Zero edition and now all of the
merch like this shirt right here's the
space babies one our new a soda inspired
shirt all of our real rejects merch is
going to be going over there and then we
got a new artist on board my sister it's
gonna be some awesome new designs that
we have coming up or I'm telling you
it's going to be great it's one of the
best ways to support the channel and
help pay for my urgent care bill milking
the pain
ladies and gentlemen leave a like on
this video
and also um hey uh another reminder full
interaction watch long recent with your
own copy of TMNT muted Mayhem available
for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all who have
joined cover several things exclusive
for their action highlights and watch
logs included but go to rejectnation
shop.com as well let's get to it
[Music]
love a good stylized bumper cool
Greg pictures I love that production
company name already winning you over
listen up we're going after Dr Baxter
Stockman
it stole billions of dollars worth of
research and created an actual mutant
mutant wow each of you has been issued a
high-powered anti-mutant neutralizer
anti-mutant neutralizer the minikin who
works against the turtles yeah bring me
Stockman's mutant and whatever he used
to
I love how it's oozed and green
stick them like a stuck Stockman
[Music]
if you like the drawing yeah they're
using like pencil Strokes for even light
I perfected the Ooze are you excited for
Daddy
I
Superfly we're safe now soon I'll make
you brothers and sisters Carlo it's all
our characters Bebop Rocksteady Mondo
Gekko I'm creating a family Bebop
Rocksteady
give them the compound V already
[Music]
oh too late oh cool it's like a horror
movie right now yeah it's very Gothic
damn
oh my God
Jeff Goldblum
[Music]
this is straight up like a horrible dude
yes
[Music]
talking about I love that there's like a
80s 90s animation style to this yeah
because people always liking it into the
spider verse in the trailers but I'm
definitely getting more like an 80s 90s
type of drawing style like when it was
created in 84 I believe it feels like
you're watching a movie some kids
sketched in their notebook yeah
[Music]
and thus the turtles were created
not bad logo not bad
that's pretty cool cool the heavy metal
logo red and orange outline you know
like pizza sauce and pizza crust
Michelangelo
Leonardo Raphael
Donna Phillip
let's go
I loved when camera tracks them like
that it's so fun
we must use stealth and cunning to
infiltrate the human world and retrieve
Gogurt hell yeah Donny you're on
toiletries Raph you're stocking up the
pantry and Mikey you're on juncus and
remember don't let any human see you
here
[Laughter]
let's go
somewhere you have bronchitis
did they record with all the teenagers
in in the same booth I think it sounds
like yeah yeah I think they did
that's just way too natural it's like
Tom Cruise Mission Impossible
nice yeah
[Music]
gotta build up Get Swole parents
Citywide are calling for a curfew until
the criminal is caught but the only lead
is a mysterious Mastermind known on the
streets as super blocks so no Shredder
this movie okay or maybe you bought from
Rock City will be here or it could be an
Easter egg there's an outdoor movie
night in Brooklyn yeah yeah I hope it's
a funny one
hopefully it's better than Tremors
because I know Raphael didn't like that
one well done
Ferris Bueller oh wow that this is a
choice yes
huh is this High School like in real
life yeah you go to high school you can
just hijack a parade whenever you want
same questions we asked when we watched
it
[Music]
oh Leo wants a goth GF this is really
interesting so they're like really
yearning for human connection
one day everyone will love us like
everyone loves Ferris Bueller
it tells me this is going
to nail about self-acceptance
[Music]
stay hidden it's actually doing a really
good job at capturing that teenage
loneliness yeah because they're not even
like looking upon adult they're not even
looking up on other teenagers looking
upon like adults actually and I know
what that feels like as a teenager to
have that feeling I make white noises
that makes it louder
boys where have you been
it's old
a Jackie Chan yeah yeah
look we're really sorry Splinter some of
the guys want to see a movie and I try
to talk them out of it
worst leader
will remember why human not disgusting
monsters why they're gonna milk us for
our blood we don't even have nipples
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's take it as an odd way to phrase
it all started 15 years ago it's much
urgent I was young red in my 20s I was
on top of the world
we have one friend he was a cockroach we
got along very well his name was a
campus
was it Kevin Eastman everything changed
oh so adorable I really love the
animation I love the art behind this a
lot whatever this proves was
he transformed us
that's so cool like seeing the actual
transformation I became older red
you guys were babies so you stay baby
you look like Squirtle yeah and then
they'll evolve into war tortol we became
a family
[Music]
oh hell yes greetings girl and welcome
to my world
I like your there is such a youthful
quality the way they drew this movie
really feels like teens put it together
it happened the most complimentary way
yeah
like a finessed version of it
when you think about like he's got to
take care of four kids by himself it's
not easy he's a single dad yeah no and I
like how they're really capturing him
being a father not just a Sensei yeah
yeah as a matter of fact how does he
become a martial artist
he's a survivalist so he learned you
were obsessed with the human world so I
decided to give her a shot oh no no stay
down there okay that guy's gonna have to
learn to accept risks
[Music]
wow
oh my God they are so adorable yeah I
want plushies of each of them in baby
form they are so cute
[Music]
oh no it didn't go well oh my God
Paramount oh yeah Nickelodeon
[Music]
jeez guys terrible oh look at the
adorable turtles
[Music]
oh that day I promised to never let you
get hurt ever again I needed to find a
way to unlock ancient secrets of
ninjutsu
okay weapon of death
and I found it
okay he learned from this yes
[Music]
oh I got it let's just learn from Cinema
television this is great
whoa
oh my God so many classic Kung Fu films
[Music]
we only need each other you boys are all
I got and you're all I'll ever had dude
Jackie Chan's killing the voice working
yeah no leave to soar for one month
seriously yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
made up my mind are you gonna get food
uncle
I just gotta get out of the sewer man I
mean I like you guys and all but I just
simply cannot live a happy life knowing
that your faces are the last things I'm
gonna see before I die
good cheese that's fair the time
actually changed the Colossus never see
that happen
Target's approaching
[Music]
The Dark Knight yeah
I love this music who did the score I
don't know but it every choice is very
transported for the exact mood and
moment
[Music]
oh
I will say the street stuff does remind
me a lot of the spider-verse movies
[Music]
that is sick I was like they gotta call
him Superfly for some reason damn strong
enough to hold an ice cream truck get
three people in it
now that's a hell of a hideout yeah
jealous I just love how disproportionate
like some of the facial features are of
people yeah
ah is he eating them I don't I seems
like it so they stole a radioactive
storage unit this time put tracking
devices on all shipments
yeah yeah
stay still gonna go viral
viral Ninja Turtles awesome come on guys
we just got ungrounded all right let's
go home is it weird to have your head so
far up Dad's butt
yo check this out in slo-mo
whoa Fruit Ninja he's gonna die hey why
do we pick a fruit shaped exactly like
my head your head looks like Scooby at a
baby with Hey Arnold
yep that's funny it's a deep reference
was that April O'Neill it was
[Music]
it's a good thing she was wearing a
helmet I know murdered her
oh
what's her deal she's yelling at us on
blocks I think she's mad that we hit her
with the ninja star I think she's asking
Leo on a date I think
the lady behind you
your scooter
you gotta be heroes now
we tried to Warner nothing more we can
do
gotta get the scooter back to this
beautiful and Charming human one
prove yourself
I I am genuinely loving this movie yeah
hasn't missed a beat so far we're gonna
need the most foolproof plan every
single ninja technique all right I need
you guys to use stealth to block the
doors you say it going loud
[Laughter]
that's a lot of guys
oh you got some ass whooping to do you
could take them we've prepared our whole
life for this I've actually been in a
fight oh no you noticed but all I've got
is a big stick oh my God this is great I
dream about fighting every night you got
a rage that's not a problem
uh
oh my God oh my God
I'm glad it wasn't the nunchucks it's
always the nunchucks
it's got shades of Ace Ventura when he
got the thing stuck in his legs
you say they look like sharks at one
point was that Street Sharks reference
oh come on Leo delegate
all right we gotta work as a team guys
oh I love capturing them on their first
fight yeah they're so unorganized right
now
woo
go ninja go ninja go
did not think we'd be hearing that song
again ninja rap we all love vanilla ice
walk softly Donatello
[Music]
woof
yeah
my goodness oh yeah this guy would have
been great in Tokyo Drift
[Music]
that was by the books really well done
I I feel like really connected to them
yeah
like my heart feels like really
connected to this you got my scooter
back so I feel like Donna you go on
first you're the most inviting
impressive
his work isn't
easy those are taken sharks uh there's
wolves up for grabs wow the costumes are
Street Sharks how do you get this on and
off that's your skin
can we explain this over some pizza
how you guys feel about pepperoni yeah
he hasn't red onions for me what about
you guys just choose
on a pizza with another Pizza on top of
the pizza Mutant baby turtles to turtle
men guys uh Turtle boys actually I would
say teens you know I would say Turtleman
teenagers teenagers call them the thing
do it
you guys are TMNT
I write for my school paper really I
assume you'd want to be on camera
because you have like a very camera
ready look
oh my
smooth my guy the police have been
talking about implementing this curfew
if they don't find him soon right I'm
trying to you know help bring into
justice so everyone could chill out or
whatever but this
do you think there are more people like
you you know people who will accept us
oh
my gosh no no absolutely not but they
can monetize you yeah I'll airdrop you
my contact and if you ever feel like you
wanna come out to the world or whatever
just let me know like how she's at least
respectful about
what the hell of her whole personality
man Iowa debris give me that contact
Pizza Hut yes
I think there was a giant commercial
about pizza before the VHS of the first
film if I remember correctly I hope
you're [__] right angry
well there was dominoes in the first
movie Roy's Pizza in the second movie
what if everyone saw says hero I mean
look
[Music]
it's like Coke and Avengers end game
sure he's a giant terrifying green
monster but everyone knows he saved them
so they're taking subies with them in a
diner yeah hello mostly improvised that
scene I know he's good on his feet
I love how much they consume media yeah
what about that though he doesn't really
need to know about it
and
you help us find Superfly we bring him
to Justice you document it all prom is
uncanceled and we get accepted by the
world as Heroes wow
wow
they have fears okay perfect yes how
about we meet tonight 8 PM Eastman High
yeah
for Kevin Eastman
[Music]
love how alive the city is too whole
thing I like how they're capturing the
underlying sadness behind the turtles
very well too yeah
[Music]
Eastman the relationship forming with
April is great I think it's wonderful is
this uh living up to your dreams
Attack on Titan attack on Titus
ever look oh my God oh my God
do we not have last names it's okay I'll
just break it up Michael Angelo Perfecto
that makes you Leonardo
uh wolf man's got nard
that reference
Monster Squad hey well at least I'm not
puke girl that is a bat oh is that April
is that April's Locker I thought I could
read the morning announcements and you
know it didn't go so well oh no oh no
[Music]
who would be on camera anxiety exciting
me feel like I was gonna explode and so
well you didn't I did
oh my God The Secret of the Ooze I was
about to say that you beat me to it
oh
my God remix
I was gonna say that's not something
anyone forgets in high school I hope we
get to see the turtles do improv it's
all the personalities feel so relatable
and distinct Superfly seems to be
building
so that's awesome nobody's ever seen his
face why because he kills everyone who
does oh maybe he's trying to rescue his
brother and sisters in their crew sure
Sharon Paul Bronson tubei Tom and normal
Nate let's start chasing him down
I like to play I wish my high school had
a dark room yeah
[Music]
great Montage
oh hell yes yes let's get an older boy
reference
love that they're actually using their
weapons calling you out
[Music]
I mean they're just straight up
Vigilantes they're not doing any ninja
[__]
teenage vigilante ninja Vigilantes
God man these these match cuts are
freaking awesome yeah
I love how Ralph's teenage rage is like
a fun bloodlust of a teenager
oh this radioactive storage unit but so
let's just love however the chest hair
looks like this yeah
the deal with Superfly is tonight under
the bridge we give him his unit and he
leaves us alone
the villainous Menace really does remind
me of like Kingpin from spider-verse
just the tone of it that it emits hey
I'm a Gangster I got my puff in my Timbs
I need my bacon egg and cheese too you
got the good Superfly
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're you're
uh-oh text from Dad
well they say Dad not Master Splinter
like it hits home a lot more surprise
you want to be in the human world and I
found your human clothes
I think I maybe found a way to make you
happy I brought the human world to you
look no
what are you doing up there don't lie
tell me is someone trying to milk you uh
do you need help anything you need I'm
here we're just running errands I hope
in the post-credits scene they're
getting milked yes
all right well hey thanks for the
surprise party appreciate it Dad we will
be leaving goodbye no no
[Music]
Ali smutter suffers from cardiac arrest
and they just weren't there for any of
it yeah it feels like Mad Max
yeah where's the Dew for here all right
guys there's two cars in the motorcycle
it's like 10 dudes Tops This is just
dragging the back into that car on the
ground speed Bob rock city is it oh yeah
super slapio
damn nipple ring yeah
my man I can milk you
there he is my man we're here to find
you I can't believe there are other
mutants like us oh this is so good 15
years ago right some sludge was dumped
in the sewer and y'all came from that
well we prefer the term ooze but yeah
just like when the professor explained
that to them in the second Turtles movie
that same ooze made me my dad Baxter
Stockman he's the one who dumped the
Ooze down the drain baby so technically
we cousins Ice Cube yeah it's Ice Cube
this is Bebop and that's Rock stick hey
what you looking at yeah bro what you
looking at right here we got Wing nuts
High Wing wave we got it
[Music]
this is leather head oh I get right
fellas Genghis frog
hey
that scumbug she only speaks
that's Mondo Gekko hey what's up what's
up Bros I like your Vibe digging your
Vibe
I ship them do you recognize that voice
he's an adventure thank you
oh Paul Rudd yeah what are you building
if we gonna chat let's go somewhere fun
yeah okay I think it's such a great flip
yeah please tell me they're gonna play
Turtles in Time that'd be amazing
they're supposed to be versus fighting
each other and it's turning into bonding
I mean they can't they can't relate to
each other they've all come from the
same thing so when they're trying to
find Community among people and finding
community in a whole other place yeah it
makes sense yo check this
oh yes
maybe you could finish explaining like
exactly where you came from and what you
want and stuff oh easy acceptance
they want the same thing my earliest
memory in the world is one day telling
me
it was accepted he just wanted a family
man oh this whole story is about
acceptance yeah but then that's when the
people we work for sent the obstacle
they took it from
Ops I rescued my little baby brother and
sister and since I was the oldest you
know I had to raise them you did a great
job you did damn it's like a splinter in
himself it's like real life in some
cases maybe they just ain't all bad we
went out we hit the town and it did I
love how personal they're making this
and now it's like a reflection of the
turtles it's so good he wouldn't stop
chasing us he wanted to kill us oh my
God that's what happened
no okay she's a hockey sticker yeah I
beat that fool damn I touched that
cheese
that is a great expression to kill all
the humans
rule the Earth whatever I built a
machine to enact my plane damn I get
where he's coming from though then we're
gonna launch it into the atmosphere and
watch it vaporize
turn everyone into the lizard I was
thinking I was just thinking that yeah
they would get their acceptance the
turtles that they want we wish there was
another way to feel safe and happy but
people's they got to go
I got this I can complete my device in
acceptance
dominance will be yours you stopping
them now you're gonna make me film you
oh you can finally have family and
friends what if we're not into the plan
I don't agree what if we don't like it
and that right there pissed me off
oh it's not real acceptance we'll drive
the van with the storage unit and uh you
lead the way so mind the wing nut Rock
ride with the tortoise
[Music]
it's interesting Bebop and rockstead are
just animals too like they didn't they
weren't first humans
a lot of them
no it might be buffing even Superfly has
Baxter Stockman right yeah yeah I
changed that here too it's go time
in their device that's small enough to
get under the seat but strong enough to
press the pedal you mean a stick I got
it a bow
bow staff
like I was doing like a pool stick yeah
[Music]
karaoke's always fun
it's like wanted yeah oh yeah good call
remix oh can they convert this into
their Turtle van I'll probably get the
numb chucks on the Turtle van now don't
worry guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
I understood that reference it's from
Superman right Superman Begins
pressure my guy whoa jeez
[Music]
maybe that won't be the turtle then and
the good thing is they know the location
no
[Music]
go go
game guy from the beginning he's got a
grudge or they had a tracking remember
they said they put tracking units on
everything April hell
abandoned by humans
now you know April's gonna bust them out
nah she's out of the movie April gang
gonna do [__] she's gonna turn into
Megan Fox yes and then leave I've been
looking for you for a long long time I
don't know what you want from us or why
you talk so scary
there's a fly monster
I'm gonna do the talking it kind of has
krang's colors I am Cynthia rose colors
April's colors
I will use you to create a stable
mutagen an army of super soldiers she's
pretty bad herself
[Music]
there it is
closed captioning not available
[Music]
smooth like butter come on guys
voice kind of sounds like Jake Gadsden
wait Jake Johnson
oh yeah
someone's here
Peter B Parker
stay back I just care for my boys lie to
me they're in so much trouble right now
oh is that so Ratatouille I was thinking
right too oh God
laughs
oh it's like an actual plasma
you're finding your calling
[Music]
a lot of us like a Jackie Chan fight
yeah totally I wonder if he had input on
the choreographer I'm sure he did
team no no no no
yeah
[Music]
oh that's awesome it's
amazing
nice yeah
get some nunchuck action
and somebody else got hit in the nuts
not the wielder that was great that was
so satisfying right funnel moment loved
it how did you find it
I'd be a pretty big piece of crap if I
didn't at least try to get your dad to
come help you oh
11 Hopper and our four boys yeah
let's get on those bikes kids there's
only one way for you to be safe and
happy and just listen to me
let's go
it's hitting deep right now just the
always lost moment starting another song
seeing you guys make so many mistakes
just to get people to like you made me
realize I was definitely doing this for
the wrong reason hey okay sometimes you
never learn
okay do this channel for so many years
sometimes that's life and then all I see
is one or two comments that it becomes a
goal to get those two people to like me
acceptance at any cost what is it about
humans that you love so much if we kill
them we are no better than they are I
refuse to accept that you all are cool
with brutally killing all of them no no
Superfly is gonna stay constant though
sometimes you know
everyone on Earth Superfly is definitely
not changing fools no we don't want to
do this we just didn't know that there
was any other alternative but we see
that there is let's
uh right you want to stop this machine
oh no I just keep doing a great job yeah
everybody man this is really well cast
[Music]
Sky beam It's gotta say that reminds
more of Mr Freeze's ice gun Batman and
Robin I think he's the reason
we gonna do
[Music]
something damn it's so weird to say rock
steady and Bebop on the good team
man up
[Music]
everyone just attacked at once
[Applause]
[Music]
if you listen to me
the error of my ways yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man
crushed to death
I think
Kaiju fly yeah the opposite at the
Lazarus Pit
ah Jurassic world Dominion
or Godzilla
sure
oh God Wowie
[Music]
whoa
I love how you can feel the weight of it
just struggling to get up yeah look at
my feet
wow they really Cronenberg
wow oh that is horrifying I love it I
don't want to be like Superfly I want
you to be happy even though I don't like
humans I want them to like you oh we're
gonna take him down we're gonna film it
we're gonna show it to you tomorrow and
the world will love you and accept you
and where would you turtles turtles
turtles
oh what happened to the whole stop
Superfly thing are we not doing that or
what's up so much has changed since we
lost spoke I love when they're Heroes
for stopping the problem they helped
create yeah love that trip
I actually might have something oh right
the anti Mutual mutagen gun it's a
covered parallel
let's leader ever Leonardo
nice
teaming up it's like a whole superhero
Team Four
it's nice yeah nice so Neil the hero
shot puke
[Music]
all right close one eye I heard that
hell
[Music]
I mean come on it's not really gonna do
anything
what the hell we're good right
I don't need that horse
you gotta go inside his mouth and shoot
him yeah you gotta fill his belly up
with the stuff
damn
love the explosions
I think we lost them
how
oh man I love this dread Heavy Music
it's a drowning bass
rampaging through downtown New York the
only question is do we capture them for
experimentation or kill them on site oh
God
mutants are attacking the city
I'm not the big Superfly be a military
response oh that's really sad is this
the world you want to protect you got to
protect it even if it doesn't understand
I think we're monsters I hope this takes
a different ending and they just start
slaughtering humans you know what we
were wrong
I know we only wanted to be heroes to be
accepted but even though it looks like
we'll never be accepted I still think we
should try to be heroes what
I mean yeah guys
it's a real hero right there I'm sorry I
shouldn't have
should have protested that
Attack on Titan giant monsters attack
and they have one weakness in the backs
of their necks
the ball is exactly that there it is
Attack on Titan is the only manga I read
it's time to go loud loud real loud
yeah she sounded like a leader I
actually was a literally agreeing
Lord this helmet was a good investment
yeah it's not for that helmet she would
have perished very early on in the film
change the narrative
keep rolling rolling she's on camera
this movie's about facing your fears
swallow it
April O'Neil here reporting live with
new and confirmed information a fly
monster is attacking the city you just
need to find something bigger than
yourself to fight for they would
definitely just let you do the news a
random teenager against the monster in
an attempt to save
the giant monsters man but the mutants
you see here are in fact good
it's okay
you think the same language as scumbag
we actually have a lot in common
oh my God
[Music]
the fours playing Forza really helped
Donnie with his driving yeah
he'll direct the forza movie
[Music]
wow
he's so old
[Music]
wow you know now that we're actually
about to die there's nothing I'd rather
be looking at oh oh I love the details
on Donny's frames
come on save your boys
damn I love how gritty this shit's
getting
[Music]
who's this guy he's gonna help hey are
you okay
do you need help someone's actually
helping I must get this to my boys
I got this
let's go New Yorkers
[Music]
you do not know New York Delivery Man
they have a common enemy this is just
like Watchmen now
to unite the world in peace to this
tragedy
this is very well coordinated I love it
[Music]
taxi cab guy too
that kickflip
nice grind
[Music]
everyone is so in sync
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work
dude you left the size in there
oh [__]
oh God this would have been so cool in
3D
yes oh got him
hell yeah
yeah
oh
the horses
[Music]
cute titles
ninjas
my ninjas
fill up
another one big happy family
not sad at all that they had to kill
their big brother who raised them
oh we're getting ready for school
that's a very different direction for
the turtles their sewers all over the
city just hop in the store you can come
home oh it's better than the subway
Teenage Mutant Ninja high school I want
to see that I'm proud of you boys I love
you we love you love you too
oh
wow wow how are we gonna know who's who
[Applause]
yeah
yeah thanks for saving us guys
what a cool mirroring from the beginning
to the end here
oh
hey bro Heroes
[Music]
boss lady
well done fantastic terrific that was
fantastic man definitely a different
direction but oh that was the animated
series that was awesome
David Fincher directed this hey hello
it's Tony and I have found my people
the it Club welcome to my Australian
shoe store do you have any Nikes no but
I do have the Australian version
Leo how many times
who is tcri
[Music]
oh my God they're going to prom tuxedo
t-shirt this is such a different
direction I love it oh you guys should
get together it is what
Baxter who is it
[Music]
yes
capturing them on the other hand
might prove difficult there is one
option
[Music]
I'm so excited I cannot wait to see that
oh my god oh
okay this definitely sounds like a Trent
rezner beat
you're wrong it's not changing chance
but I did I didn't think it sounded like
him though and they're all like actual
kids yeah yeah the kid the the turtles
are for sure alrighty alrighty we got 20
minutes to chat
I'm going to fill up this entire time
everyone
Joy go first Andrew I really enjoyed it
like I said it was a different take on
what plenty John
no no go ahead
it was it was a different take on what
uh we're used to seeing I love the whole
theme of acceptance it was something I
think we all relate to I mean I'm still
trying to gain Acceptance in this world
because good luck being you everyone
hates me everyone says I'm a reference
machine it still doesn't like me
but also too I mean we know also you
know just like coming back even to like
Splinter yes he's always been a father
figure and they're Sensei and all that
but like you'll never be accepted it
really hit a lot deeper on this because
I mean just little things in this like
yes again he always felt like a father
figure in the movies in the TV show but
like that like little things like them
actually calling him dad and stuff like
that and then like Leo wanting to have a
romantic interest and then that with
April I mean there were just so many
little things that I just was like
getting so invested in and I love the
the animation and and I mean there were
other things too I wasn't expecting like
there was like levels of horror in this
too with like the superfly uh played by
Ice Cube very brilliantly I mean I had
like just eating people and stuff like
that and then the whole plan itself was
actually really horrific if you think
about what he was trying to do with the
whole Amazing Spider-Man lizard uh
turning everyone into mutants like that
was really uh scary but I love the whole
idea too of the turtles like having this
you know the juxtaposition of okay look
we want everyone to accept us but like
you know and then also Splinter has been
teaching us for forever like that you
know this world is like there's a lot of
evil people out here who will not accept
us and we can turn this whole world into
mutants kind of thing and people will
now or mutants now will accept us that
will be a in a world amongst ourselves
and they make the hard decision they
make the hero decision like no that's
not right and I thought that was really
deep and there were a lot of different
other things I like but I don't want to
hog up on you guys go ahead
well you know
about who you want to be accepted by and
what you want to be accepted for and I
think that was very exciting it's never
getting accepted never see that's the
thing is I don't surprised you enjoyed
this at all because I don't think you
know it'll be ever possible for you to
relate yeah you were like the turtles in
this movie but only the first like
everything before the finale it's like
that news report they had where they
were like surrounded by fire and they
looked really menacing you that's where
you're identifying with it ends right
there after that you can't relate then
you're like what is this everyone's
celebrating I don't understand at all I
bet you guys know me so well it's okay
Andrew it's because we don't accept you
he is we don't accept you we judge you
we judge and our judgment is uh
correctness that's fine please I'm sorry
um I interrupted you because this
nuisance was talking about us it's okay
it's fine I I appreciate you apologizing
on his behalf uh no I love this from
front to back uh it will probably have a
lot of the similar things to say but
yeah this moved with like an
effortlessness of pace it was so well
proportioned it had such a lovely spirit
and especially in the first 10 or 15
minutes it was moving between a lot of
different things but it had a really
gradual and very smooth grip on how to
do that there are certain voices that
don't get to speak very much but on the
whole the voice cast is terrific and
just yeah I loved loved what they did
with the animation here because
spiderverse has opened up such a door
for what we think of when we think of a
computer animated movie like this and
there is so much love for other styles
of Animation out there and so this
managed to Encompass to take that leap
that spider-verse perhaps presents and
do something kind of its own with it and
to hearken I don't have like the best
lexicon of Turtles comics but having
this like scuzzy or more asymmetric Ice
uh asymmetric design style felt kind of
like something I would uh look at in you
know like an old panel from one of those
it had some of that Gonzo quality while
still being very family accessible and
uh and just yeah like so many lovely
little choices like all those scribbly
whip pans and like the Halos of light
that feel like just yeah white pencil
scribbles and stuff and and the way they
pitted everybody in a position where
they need some kind of acceptance but
they're all approaching it from
different motivations and angles like
this was
I I would assert that you know with a
few basic ingredients you can make a
satisfying Turtles movie but they just
went Above and Beyond on everything so
yeah I this absolutely I think deserves
to be one of the top movies of the Year
this was so great
Commander
uh-huh you want me to continue yes uh I
also like how you might gain our
acceptance
just throwing you off for a game all
right
um
oh God what did you talk about and what
did you talk about
and what did I talk about all right I
guess I'll bring theories to the game
here
I think I laid out pretty much
everything that I loved about it during
the reaction
um and then I'm sure more will come out
during it I feel like this Cynthia utron
person
my theory
here's my theory does everyone want to
hear my theory what's your theory or
accept it automatically I think
praying is inside of her I think she's a
machine that'd be awesome
yeah that would be oh that's a good
Theory actually yes that's mine I accept
it very good that's my theory for that
and I like what they're building up for
I mean because
I mean she said she's huge from and just
there's something about the way she was
coming granted everyone kind of had a
strange disproportionate design a lot of
the humans looked a little bit off not
all them but some of them did and I feel
like there's something to her specific
physique and Bill that felt a little bit
android-like and there and something
about the type of uh tenor in her voice
that specifically sounded a bit like she
was channeling what we kind of associate
with the voice of Krang
sure and that is why I wouldn't go there
um and I love the ominous
teas that they have there at Shredder at
the end and give it something more
personal I was surprised by this film
significantly uh I I was really enamored
from it from beginning to end you know I
think out of all the turtles movies this
I call it recency I got a little bit of
criticisms of a couple of things but for
the most part I think out of all the
turtles films
this might be up there as my favorite
one even though there's a couple of
things I wish that they did do and a
couple of things that wasn't that didn't
click as strong for me as I may have
hoped there's there's some stuff that I
thought the intention was very strong
and I loved the idea and there's a lot
of it that I did like and then there's
like other qualities to it that I was
like I just didn't quite fully 100 hit
the mark for me because obviously the
turtles I thought great the camaraderie
the bonding with them was excellent uh
Splinter I I this I I think I think
people would have a lot of gripe with
Splinter here uh like for people who are
like fans of Ninja Turtle because he's
like such a dad he's not really like the
ninja background and in fact it's one of
the things about this movie that I was
like there's no real like ninja stuff
yeah and here you know they just
straight up become like Vigilantes and
then they're now accepted in high school
and they're receptive by the world which
I love the arc and I love the trajectory
of that and we've seen so much different
kinds of there's there's countless types
of Ninja Turtles properties that I'm not
exactly perturbed uh by that you know a
lot of people wanted to go down the
specific direction that we're all sort
of familiar with and you know there is
that Association of like out of the
shadows and whatnot
however I think this direction is very
different especially when it comes to
like the film the film medium for uh the
Ninja Turtles I think it's an excellent
direction to go and just something that
we haven't seen before it's kind of like
when
um you know Spider-Man's identity
getting revealed at the end of far from
home like oh damn what's this gonna do
this is gonna be like very different and
that's Iron Man and that's a very and I
am Iron Man like that this is a very
different type of approach that I really
like uh to to explore here because it
really captures the the heart and soul
of what it's like to be a teenager uh in
a wide variety of areas and it really
captures like the New York Spirit of
what I know from films and the couple of
times I've been to New York you know and
the New York pizzas I have eaten it
captures that Flair that eccentricity
and I I love the concept of the of the
superfly family and everything they
represented and especially thematically
for how that is a thematic for what that
mirrors with Splinter's Journey
thematically for what that mirrors for
uh the turtles Journey all that there
were just times though where I I did
kind of feel like it needed a
uh I think it's because there was so
much heart and soul and so much layers
to the the bonding of the turtles and
then that family was just everyone there
was just kind of one note and it's I
know it's like an animated movie it's an
hour and a half but everyone was just
kind of like
if I were to do an impression of all
them in one sentence it'd be I'm the
family yeah
this is all the books so you know well
because I know their lines are just
during action so they're saying action
lines yeah and like they were all pretty
much like some variation of Mondo gecko
you know sure you know and and I I did
when like Superfly is such a a a a a
nuanced villain and I think a great
villain and I thought that kind of
missed it to the so I I I would have
kind of felt a little bit more of that
emotional catharsis
if I felt that they were more real
characters it was the only time when I
felt like
celebrity voice cameos where everyone
else was just like pure perfect Talent
yeah you know and that felt like
celebrity voice cameos even Paul Rudd
like I enjoyed Mondo Gekko but I was
Paul wrote you know uh so yeah like it's
not like I didn't like them I I just I
loved so I loved the world the aura the
tone the animation everything you guys
touched on Splinter every one of the
turtles I loved it all and then the
movie does take time to you know give a
good amount of screen time to this other
family which is very important and
Integra I love the idea of them so much
and I do feel like they kind of miss the
emotional beat Mark which I do feel is
an integral part when it is
ending on the note of they are joining
to be one big cohesive one big family
down in the sewers and grow together
like it is a an important aspect to the
film and I I did crave that so that's my
that's my one thing that I'm missing
from it but other than that I do think
it is like one of the best memories I've
seen of the year and it is so really
strong and it might be up there as my
favorite I want to revisit the original
1990 Turtles uh I would say those are my
two the 1990 and this one I want to
revisit that one before I make because I
I was listening to a review from red
letter media about it and then I was
like you know I really don't remember
this movie
it still holds up for me I love that
movie they were showing scenes I was
like I don't know any of this like I
don't remember Jack about it and so I
wanna I know I've seen it though so I
want to revisit it not going to do a
reaction or maybe I don't know uh but I
want to revisit it yeah and before I
make that statement but right now for
with like I remember Secret of the Ooze
very well because for some reason I
watch that's more kid-friendly yes I
watch that all the time and I watch the
part three all the time
um so I I don't so I I don't want to say
this is my favorite one but but it's up
there it's it's definitely up there even
though they didn't have the ninja
quality it's definitely up there
um yeah I think they could have also
used maybe just a pinch of conflict
between the rest of the family having to
go against the guy who raised them and
then afterwards maybe mourning him a
little yeah exactly you know yeah
because there was no there could have
been a they set up such a fascinating
debate like the second the turtles were
like oh my God wait a minute
the story is so much about acceptance
and these can be the the uh the extended
family where they could find the
acceptance and it seemed like they had
that room for such an interesting
conversation
and but because the rest of the family
was just kind of
like just one note yeah I do agree the
way that they got the other family to
flip so quickly on Superfly after years
of him nurturing them and being a family
like damn that was a quick flip like one
speech and you're done with Superfly I'm
like again what Leo and the rest of
turtles were saying like made sense and
I I get why they would change their mind
I'm like damn that was yeah quick you
guys just finished your mind and
especially because they established that
Superfly has the intelligence of Baxter
Stockman yeah that he would have the
emotional capacity to be able to instill
but then again he is very like strong
yeah he's like he's he's more imbued in
like yeah hatred and revenge yeah he's
probably an emotionally closed off
Father Figure he's probably I mean
because of what he's had to go through
and I think to like the way that they
decide ultimately like oh yeah we don't
want to do this is amusing in the moment
I appreciated of course in isolation but
because it's sort of nonchalant and then
everyone's like yeah we don't want to do
this I feel like it does kind of sap
again a potential moment for True
conflict
emotional and I know I'm probably gonna
get ripped for this but whatever
um but I know
the least the least again I know you
guys are gonna be like of all the things
you found to be least believable in this
film a Superfly growing all this I don't
know about April being just allowed to
be alive
I just don't put by it okay half the
people I will set the building yeah I
will accept the camera man yeah exactly
uh I will say well it's because Bruce
Wayne called them and told him to get
out of the building
um I will say this though I'm glad and
even though they did address it in the
film that was one of my favorite moments
for for Leonardo in terms of addressing
the team and like having his leader
moment because that's one of the things
that has been like especially is such a
big Leonardo stand like God he's such a
terrible leader but I still love him I'm
like and you uh Dressed it you're like
Alfred loser like I've kind of felt that
way so many times when I've watched on
Instagram like he's such a terrible
leader yeah but in this film like and he
got his moment but I'm glad they
addressed it in the film like that was
such a great leader moment for you like
and but and like when he addressed the
team he he gave that like he was
coordinating on what they needed to do
and he gave the great speech like but it
was like really well earned too like it
didn't yeah it didn't feel like oh
here's the moment it just feels like
yeah it was naturally yeah and I think
Jackie Chan I mean again all the cast
was really good other than I know the
point you made about the celebrity Cameo
and stuff but all the turtles
Ayo is April fantastic
she was fantastic I love what Jackie
Chan did as Splinter and again the like
you said the different approach they did
with splinter in terms of because from
what we got I remember in the films he
was you know uh um was it a Mata Yoshi's
uh Rat and then that's how he
yeah exactly and then I love too and the
way he was fighting like the really
choreographing that his fights like
according to like how Jackie Chan would
fight in real life too was really like
kind of meta in itself as well but I
just again I I really love Kevin Clash
and uh the first two films and then I
really liked Mako and the the film that
you uh John and I reacted to but yeah
Jackie Chan just really like I just
really felt the camaraderie he had with
his children it was so endearing and so
cute and so Charming this was the most
emotional I've ever felt towards any
towards the turtles and this and
Splinter especially like I thought the
heart just felt so genuine I cared so
much and I was from when I when I
realized that they were like oh this is
their first fight they're gonna have
I was really rooting for them I'm like
damn I've never like rooted so much for
these guys on an emotional Journey
before or physical like I really really
care about them as like kids you know
and I've never had that for them like
I've always liked them and of course I
root for them it's just not to this
extent not to this level you know find
yourself like identifying quite as
heavily as you do here yeah yeah I
thought everyone made they made very in
April too very very relatable and like
the way they modernize the the
friendship and how that went down and
and the way their their camaraderie
formed I was like this is like
believable
I'm I'm just super grateful April was
wearing that helmet at the beginning
because this film would have been super
short yeah yeah Teenage Mutant Ninja
murderers yes right great music too as
we've kept pointing out yeah
um great cinematography and I can't wait
for the sequel like for that possible
Theory and then obviously we get the
great Shredder
um so I think it's great that they save
Shredder you know yeah no I mean we've
seen Shredder done plenty of time so I
mean I feel like they're building up
like a joker in darkness yeah exactly
begins with the joker card here at the
end
Batman's the hero Gotham and then now we
got Joker yeah yeah and then now we're
doing that here where the turtles are
accepted and loved and now the
Shredder's gonna have to because yeah
they you got to find a way to I mean
there's got to be a way to manipulate
because the part of it was like oh Bebop
and Rock City or I didn't hear it good
but I think are they doing something
here where Bebop because I mean the big
Association is be bop and Rock City work
for Shredder so it's gonna somehow we're
gonna break up the family yeah he's got
to find some Sinister way to get in
there psychologically to them I feel
like there's a way to like really dark
it up because I what I love too is how
gritty the finale was getting like it
was getting really Grim right now yeah
and I like that I like when the I've
I've I've never I can't recall seeing
that it was It was kind of disturbing
when when Superfly is cracking
yeah yeah that was kind of disturbing
yeah and it had a good a good
conscientious sense for when to borrow
like you were like oh this is kind of
like a Magneto plan and it's kind of
like this movie or that movie like they
they borrowed from other movies in very
conscientious ways to the point where
it's like oh cool I can clearly see what
you're doing but also it kind of reads
like a reference or something like that
and it makes sense it feels fresh in
this world yeah I thought the arcs of
everyone were were fantastic about the
leadership points love splinters Arc I
love them learning so much from like
watching television that's something
that I especially identify with growing
up and not really knowing how to be I
would often emulate or mirror
personalities I would see in movies and
shows and I'm like oh I really I I just
really identified with them this time
yeah it was it was really cool it was a
really cool experience as I explained
too in the TMNT 2007 uh at the end in
the review the ultimate meta thing for
me is I learned how to do mouth to mouth
CPR which is what helped me which would
help me save my mother's life right
after I watched the third film so I
learned a lot from these films so yeah
um which again I I can really relate to
how they're learning from that which is
because I learned from watching them so
they know what they're doing man yeah
it's good stuff it's good stuff good
um but guys hey
um I thank you guys so much for uh being
here appreciate all the love appreciate
all the time Andrew thank you for being
here thank you for accepting or not
accepting me drop in the references it's
okay I kind of accept you now and hey
let's end this with a patron of the day
shout out you know who I accept
Eric Horseman oh you know why accept
Eric Horseman because of my actual
birthday he's the only one who made an
Instagram post about me from the patrons
here in the shout out list Eric only one
well done buddy he didn't accept it he
didn't
but you did you were jerks we're both
Eric now I accept you my friend and it
is one of my life missions to make it to
Atlanta and then be able to hang out
with you buddy still have the real
rejects tattoo on there is that crazy oh
my God that's awesome I love you man and
um just know that if there's anyone here
at the patreon that I accept
to you everyone else has still got a
while to go but you everyone's got a lot
of Instagram posts we've got the most
accepted in this heart right now buddy I
love the hell out of you I give you a
big smooch on the lips
give you a big
eat your meatballs
swallow your spaghetti
give me that cream sauce that Alfredo
Eric Horseman this is what this is
to the tear
frauds
[Music]